i really didn't know uh i'm going i'm
hearing kids guys can you stop
this is like your first time at work
with me you're kidding me
well that is
kim kardashian goes into full mom mode
as her sons satan sam interrupt her
tonight show interview multiple times
it's so crazy
so the whole bring your kids to work day
didn't go as planned for the beauty
mogul as kim began talking to jimmy
fallon about her experience on saturday
night live they both heard kids voices
in the audience
i really didn't know uh i'm not i'm
hearing kids guys can you stop
this is like your first time at work
with me you're kidding me
your kids are right there um
well that is
who is my my two boys are here and then
my friend tracy's daughter remy's here
with them hi remy
hi boys welcome boys are here and i hear
them making so much noise guys this is
your first time at work with me don't
mess this up
you'd think it would stop after their
first scolding right yep but as kim
started explaining their big sis north's
ninth birthday party it happened again
so she wanted to have a spooky
wilderness themed
birthday party so i took them out
camping in the wilderness guys seriously
you got it you gotta go
you don't have you don't have to they
can go back if you don't feel like being
out here it's fine okay saw me left yeah
someone he was being loud okay yeah
things got quieter once kim's youngest
kiddo left and saint only participated
when he was asked like when kim wanted
feedback on an impromptu facial she gave
jimmy you gotta wake it up am i doing a
good job saint help me please sane
saint get over here and help me please
am i doing okay
now saint and some didn't just cause a
stir on the tonight show you just gotta
roll with it
ahead of the taping kim's boys joined
her for an instagram live chat and
things got a little chaotic
who's this cutie
sami sami camilla what's the man mr man
you missed a man
say hi hi
this is called instagram live hi weirdos
hey stop it hi vloggers if you're
watching this i hate you hey it's st i'm
watson
look what you're teaching them but saint
and some aren't the only ones giving kim
a tough time it's kim kardashian west
and i just wanted to talk to you and
northwest
yeah kim's eldest north knows a thing or
two about interrupting mom at work too
like back in 2020 when kim was trying to
film a psa about social distancing
okay so guys we just want
you
to social distance there's so many fun
amazing projects you can do you can
spend time with your kids and have so
much fun
trust me i want to get out
more than you know
and how could we forget the time kim
locked herself in the bathroom to film a
makeup tutorial but northie wasn't
having it i'm hiding in the guest room
you guys i'm hiding in the guest room
because my kids
will not leave me alone hey that's me
kim we salute you for being a
hard-working mom as her mom kris jenner
once famously said kim you're doing
amazing
[Music]
you